The joe rogan experience,
you know?
Yeah.
And I've always admired that.
You figured out when we were really young,
I mean when I met you,
you quit and you know,
we were both in our early twenties and you were like,
fuck this,
I'm not,
I'm not going down that road.
And you didn't need anything.
You didn't,
you didn't need alcoholics anonymous.
He like,
no,
not doing it.
I did some therapy that helped.
I just needed to realize that once I realized that and I had gone to Alanen
because of my dad adult child of alcoholic meetings,
which helped me phenomenal amount just to realize that,
um,
that it's a disease and that,
you know,
you're powerless to it.
And that for me,
I was able to apply what I learned in there.
Cause I went to a couple AA meetings and in Boston it was like guys would get up
and they were like,
and then I blew a guy for a sandwich and I passed out in a fucking dumb,
you know,
it's like I couldn't relate.
I mean,
my thing was like,
I fucked a fat chick,
you know,
that was my bottom.
I had a three way with a couple of girls who were,
uh,
you know,
placentas jump Annette.
And so,
uh,
so I could but,
but I,
I read the literature of the 12 steps and it helped me because it made me
realize that when I wanted to drink something was going on and to this day I
just have that reaction.
I know that I still want to drink all the time,
but when I really want to drink I stopped and I go,
all right,
what's stressing you out?
What do you need to deal with?
And then I just kind of focus on it.
No,
yeah,
there was,
um,
when I was a kid,
my,
uh,
my dad was an architect and so I'd worked on a lot of construction sites and I
met a lot of junkies,
a lot of junkies,
a lot of people in construction sites are either alcoholics or drug addicts.
And there was this one guy that I really liked.
He was a funny guy,
man,
really funny guy.
And he's in the band.
His name was Robbie.
Funny fucking dude,
loved hanging around with them,
but just stay off the coke,
couldn't stay off the coke and you could totally tell he would.
And he would,
he'd be honest about it to see how he went off the rails and,
you know,
and you know,
and he would,
we would be working together.
He was a carpenter and I was,
you know,
like a,
a labor.
So I was like an apprentice and so he'd be,
you know,
talking to me why he's explained to me how to do things and stuff like that.
And uh,
it's like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm just fucking tired of this.
I'm getting my shit together.
The bands getting back together,
game,
we're writing songs and this and that.
And then he come in and Monday looking like shit,
just looking like shit,
real grumpy,
didn't want to talk,
had a headache and you know,
and he didn't meant it,
you know,
went off the rail.
The saddest thing is that when you first start doing drugs,
and I dunno about you,
but I,
I had a phenomenal time doing cocaine.
You know,
I mushrooms and all this stuff I did as a teenager was like beef.
I never got hooked on it.
And if you do it,
you know,
maybe I did coke 50 times without ever getting hooked.
It's a blast.
That's the,
that's the best kept secret.
But then once you get hooked,
you're not having fun anymore.
You're just maintaining,
you're just feeding it.
See adult crash,
you know,
with,
with heroin,
you're just trying to avoid withdrawals.
You're not even feeling that great anymore.
I think with Robbie to,
part of the problem was he was very disappointed in himself.
Yeah.
And it was booze too.
He would just go off the rails and try to keep it,
you know,
it's like
there's a lot of people out there that they have a dream and then the pressure
of trying to reach that dream,
like his dream is to be in a successful band.
Right.
And the pressure of trying to reach that dream and see it to fruition,
it's just seems,
it seems unreachable.
Yeah.
It seems too far off.
And here you are,
you're,
you're in your thirties and you're working in a construction job and you know,
you fucking work all day in Boston in the winter,
you're tired as shit when you get home,
you don't want to go to band practice.
You get home at six 30 have dinner,
now it's seven 30 you got to get up,
right?
You've got to get up in a few hours.
What are you doing?
When are you going to bed?
You know,
you've got to get up at six then you go to band practice and the drummer doesn't
shell ups and can't practice or he's 45 minutes late,
his car breaks down and you're fucking pissed and screaming at you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then try to have a relationship on top of that.
Tell that girl you can't go out on Saturday night ever cause you're doing gigs
and then the Gig suck and you're not making any money.
And they're like,
she should get a job.
The GIG sock,
you should get a job and then you're in a band.
So girls are throwing themselves at,
you have an affair.
She's got some coke now.
It's good.
No,
sorry.
Turned around.
Turn it around now it's exciting again,
sometimes when I've worked at casino,
there will always be that band in the lounge is playing like born to be wild and
all those songs and like you'll see people that are like 57 dancing and you and
you see them in their dancing and it's like they're just reliving the only joy
they had in their life,
which was like when they were young dancing a rock and this band is fucking,
they're gods to them.
Mm.
The time when you're young,
when you're having fun is so fleeting.
Yeah.
Then all of a sudden responsibility stuck up and all a sudden,
you know,
you have to pay bills,
you have obligations.
You have so much to,
you have to think about.
Yeah.
For so many people,
there's just,
there's this period of their life where they looked back to whimsically I,
that was the time when I was free.
I was young.
My Dick got hard all the time.
I could go two or three times,
three times in a night.
You like,
shit man,
I can't
leave it.
And you think anything is possible.
I mean that's really,
it can happen.
That's the loss of innocence is when you realize that a certain point that you
do have to pick a path and stay on it.
Oh yeah,
you better.
He cause you gotta pay the bills with it and you know,
and then what's so sad is you see people that work so fucking hard for not a lot
of money and you know,
Bill's just add up and then they save just enough when they get their vacation
twice a year,
the good alike accrues and they'll just drink nonstop for a week.
And at the end of it,
they're just hung over.
They blew the excess money they had.
And that was it.
That's what you worked all year four.
I had a friend of mine,
I work in a restaurant and uh,
one of the guys who worked with saved up his money for eight years,
went to Vegas and blew in in one day.
Ha ha ha.
Oh,
it was the most heartbreaking story.
this poor guy.
I think he was a dishwasher.
And he worked there for eight years and set aside 50 here,
25 they're set aside for eight fucking years.
Yeah.
And I think it was some good amount of money,
like $30,000 Shit went there with a plan.
This is it,
baby.
I'm good at blackjack or whatever the fuck he played.
He read a book of guys read books.
Okay.